We have a great phrase
today on the Bloomberg
talking about a year of fire and ice.
The decade began really
with everything crumbling
and a lot of panic.
And now we're sort of
heading into a new year
when apparently nothing can go wrong.
There was some feeling in The White House
that this virus was so
contagious that it was almost
inevitable that people
were going to get it.
For weeks and weeks, China
and the WHO was downplaying
what was happening.
There was resistance To
impose a strict lockdown
because it's one of the
industrial hubs of Italy.
The outbreak itself is
unprecedented but divisiveness
in which it is evolving is unprecedented.
The idea back then that a
vaccine would be the way out
of this was quite crazy at the beginning.
We have it totally under control,
it's one person coming in from China.
We have to operate in a political context.
We were in uncharted territory.
Everything we did was right.
2020 was a year like no other.
It was a tale of government
missteps, missed opportunities
to contain the virus and
mixed messaging that left many
uncertain of the risks
and divided on the cures.
2021 begins with reasons for optimism
but experts see more viral threats ahead.
If we have any hope to bring
an end to this pandemic,
in which at least 2
million are expected to die
and protect against future
outbreaks, we need to understand
what went wrong with our global response.
Starting at the beginning.
I still remember the first
time we saw a report,
actually stock started tanking
because there was this rumor
circulating online that there
was a mysterious pneumonia
that was detected in Wuhan.
There is growing concern across Asia,
as the Wuhan pneumonia
outbreak continues to spread.
I'd actually just come back from Wuhan
reporting on a separate story.
And I still remember us joking about,
good thing you didn't
fall sick and you know,
we hope you didn't catch anything.
In early January, hospitals in Wuhan
faced an onslaught of
severely sick patients
and antibiotic treatments weren't working.
The local healthcare system
started to break down.
We sent a couple of headlines
and we were kind of like,
oh wouldn't it be crazy
if there was another SARS.
China has announced the
first death from an outbreak
of pneumonia caused by
an unidentified virus.
By January 10th, Chinese
scientists have mapped
out the genetic makeup of
the virus that will be shared
with infectious disease experts worldwide.
At that time, 41 people were
diagnosed with the virus.
It was a gradual evolution and awareness
of just how bad it could be.
It went from a curiosity to
over a period of a few months,
an impending disaster.
Within weeks the pathogen is running riot
throughout Wuhan's
population of 11 million.
As well as the broader central
Chinese province of Hubei.
And then on January 23rd,
they shut down Wuhan.
And that was the moment we
knew that it was serious.
A city of 11 million
people with almost no one
on the streets.
People in Wuhan have
been asked not to leave
the city and outsiders have
been told to stay away.
It took effect at 10:00 a.m. the next day.
Even people in Wuhan didn't
know what it really meant.
It's kind of difficult to
get the perspective of how
drastic a move that was back then.
When that happened and they announced that
they were quarantining
Wuhan, that was pretty much
the biggest quarantine that
anybody had ever experienced
in recent history.
Groceries were flying off the shelves.
People were stocking up.
People were trying to get out,
trying to get on the last train,
trying to drive out of the city.
There was a lot of confusing information.
I wanted to get my medication
but this pharmacy is closed.
If the situation continues
for one Or two more weeks,
it'll get more complicated.
What took people by
surprise is that you know,
the message on China for so long was that
it was not a big deal and
suddenly they escalated it
so abruptly with not laying
the groundwork with anybody.
China's still uncontrolled viral outbreak
comes just ahead of the week
long Lunar New Year holidays.
It's the biggest annual
human migration in the world.
When millions of tourists fan
out across Asia and Europe.
Public health experts
feared a massive seeding
of the virus across the globe.
The government prevented a lot of people
from returning to the cities
after Chinese New Year.
And that really affected
a lot of people you know,
they weren't able to make money.
They weren't able to
go back to their jobs.
And I think that that was
a really crucial moment
in just establishing the fact
that we were in uncharted
territory and that
everything going on was now
on a level that had never
experienced for a long time.
By the end of January,
the World Health Organization
declared the virus
a public health emergency
of international concern.
It wouldn't call it a
pandemic until March 11th.
Some critics fault it for being too slow.
A WHO official said the
organization had been sounding
the alarm well before
making its official call.
Once you label something as a pandemic,
there is a tendency on the part
of certain groups of people
to shrug their shoulders and
say, oh no, pandemic is here,
we just might as well get
on and limit the damage
as much as possible.
Whereas the message that
we all wanted to convey
from the end of January was,
this is a really nasty virus,
don't underestimate it.
The most challenging part
of that initial phase
of the crisis is that,
for weeks and weeks,
China and the WHO who was
downplaying what was happening.
Wuhan finally admitted those
human to human transmission
but they were saying
there was not that much.
WHO repeated that.
At this point, the Chinese government
was under heavy criticism for
not communicating effectively
with the public.
Releasing little information on the size
and scope of the crisis.
China wanted to keep people
from coming in to investigate
the origin of the virus,
which is still an extremely
sensitive topic in China right now.
The WHO was widely criticized
by the international
community for praising China
in the early stages of the pandemic.
But according to the
WHO, they had no choice.
People who are given
responsibility in public health,
we are not able just to
call the shots all the time.
We have to operate in a political context.
Our colleagues in China were
dealing with an acute problem.
Were trying to collect data
about that acute problem.
Were trying also to
work inside the country
on how severe it was.
Were then deciding to close down a city
of several million population
very, very quickly.
A lot of China's missteps
came from the virus
being so new and no
country ever having dealt
with such a situation before.
China as a political system has a tendency
towards nondisclosure.
And when there is something
unknown they have a tendency
to want things to be stable, to be quiet.
They always err on the
side of not doing anything,
not saying anything.
There was also a lot of
information leaking out
on social media, some of
that would get censored.
It's very difficult to tell what was real
and what was not real.
Public information about the novel virus,
its symptoms and level of
contagiousness were limited.
Some experts did try to raise the alarm.
When Li Wenliang died, he
Was a doctor who had warned
his former classmates and
his friends about a virus
that he had heard was spreading
and had made other doctors
sick and he was saying,
it could be another SARS
and that everybody
should take precautions.
And the government sanctioned him
and other people in the WeChat group.
That was really one of the
moments when it became clear
to both the government and
the international community
just how much was at stake.
It wasn't just about containing the virus
but it was what the virus stood
for which was whether or not
the Chinese system would
prevail and whether or not
all of the things that people
give up would ultimately
benefit them if it meant that
their government could contain
this deadly pandemic.
China was also reluctant to let
World Health Organization
infectious disease experts
into the country until the
disease had already spread
around the globe.
The WHO ultimately did
send the team to China
but the trip was extremely
tightly controlled
by the government.
It also wasn't clear
what China's plan was.
It had shut down Wuhan
and had shut down Hubei
but it was still struggling to communicate
with the rest of the
world what was going on.
And it hadn't shut China's borders yet
to the rest of the world.
With approximately 10,000 confirmed cases
of COVID in China, the Trump
administration uses travel
restrictions to limit the
transmission risk from China.
Any U.S. citizen returning
to the United States
who has been in Hubei Province
in the previous 14 days
will be subject to up to 14
days of mandatory quarantine.
The Chinese people together
with the Chinese government
have gone through
huge difficulties and
made great sacrifices.
Globally, China has
also fulfilled its duty
of helping control the
spread of the virus.
While Wuhan would remain
under strict lockdown,
the virus then known
officially as SARS-CoV-2
had jumped to Japan, South
Korea, Australia and Europe.
It's destructive force
was keenly felt in Italy.
Specifically it's
business center of Milan.
I went with my kids to the
kindergarten to tell a bunch
of five years old kid, what
does it mean being a journalist.
And then we left in the evening
to go to my parents place,
which is near Venice.
As soon as we got to the Venice
area, the number of cases
in Italy had already
jumped from one to dozens.
And as I was going to bed,
I got a WhatsApp message
confirming the first Italian fatalities
related to coronavirus.
Two more people had died
so, that is 14 deaths in Italy.
And the number has also jumped,
it is now more than 500.
There, there was resistance
to impose a strict lockdown
because it's one of the
industrial hubs of Italy.
Some leaders were saying
Milan is open for business.
Failure to quickly take
action would result
in massive deaths at nursing
homes from a complex disease
the virus causes called COVID-19.
Milan's hospital system is so overwhelmed
that makeshift morgues are required.
Italian prime minister
Giuseppe Conte pushed
the world's eighth largest
economy with more than
60 million inhabitants
into virtual quarantine.
A preview of what was to come in New York,
Sao Paolo and Mumbai.
We were the first Western
country to face the pandemic.
No one had before an experienced
so, we were essentially
leading the way,
obviously not a great way,
for the rest of the Western world.
Even as Italy locked
down, the virus stormed
across Western Europe
and into the middle East,
eventually landing on American shores
as outbreaks took hold in
both Seattle and New York.
But unlike countries like
China and South Korea
that took swift and dramatic
government led action
to contain the spread of the
virus, President Donald Trump
downplays the risk and
projects confidence.
That's the thing that I
still don't fully understand,
is how come there was a very
clear account of what to do
to get on top of this that came back
from this joint mission in China.
What was it that led so
many countries to conclude
that they would not follow
the lessons from that China
experience and they would
go about it differently?
Worries about a pandemic at this point?
No, we're not at all and we
have it totally under control.
It's one person, coming in from China
and we have it under control,
it's gonna be just fine.
He knew that the virus
could be very dangerous.
He'd been told in classified
briefings that this could
really rip through the nation
and kill a lot of people.
Jennifer Jacobs is Bloomberg
Senior White House Reporter.
He didn't wanna be alarmist.
He didn't want people to
stop going out and shopping
and to keeping the economy moving forward.
Mr. President, happy Super Bowl Day.
Thank you very much yeah, thank you.
Corona virus, I think we're
now up to our 8th case
in the United States.
How concerned are you?
Well, we pretty much shut it
down coming in from China.
We can't have thousands
of people coming in
who may have this
problem, the Corona virus.
On February 5th, this cases began to show
in the United States.
The CDC would send testing kits
to labs around the country.
However, soon after those
kits would ultimately prove
to have a faulty component,
delaying widespread testing
in the U.S. until March
and allowing the virus
to spread undetected.
And New York City would be
the hardest hit early on.
I'm an attending physician
at the Mount Sinai Queens Hospital,
we had over 60 patients
waiting for a hospital bed.
I'm seeing young people, old patients,
people of all age ranges who
are just incredibly sick.
I can't imagine my family
being here with no one.
So I have to hold their
hand while they pass away,
at least somebody is there, you know?
Cities around the U.S. moved to lockdowns
to control the spread and
prevent hospital systems
from becoming overwhelmed.
He started off with these
press briefings back in March
where he was telling the
public about the coronavirus
and what they should do.
We continue to marshall
every resource at America's
disposal in the fight
against the Chinese virus.
The President really thrives
in front of the camera,
it's one of his favorite things to do.
And there was a window of
time when he really had
the nation's attention.
We at war and the Crusades were at war.
But one of his strengths
in front of the camera
is that he likes to lib.
I would like you to speak
to the medical doctors
to see if there's any way
that you can apply light
and heat to cure.
And again I say, maybe
he can, maybe he can't,
I'm not a doctor but I'm like
a person that has a good,
you know what.
In public health those officials say,
if you don't have one
message, one unified message,
you don't have any message.
There were a lot of instances
where the government
just sent mixed signals.
What I saw not working
well during this pandemic
was communication and
public health messaging.
It's very clear that we need
a clear authoritative voice
that we trust that can
unite us as a country
and that can guide us with
the best scientific evidence.
But scientific evidence can change.
And a lack of clear and
consistent messaging
from The White House would
contribute to face masks
becoming a divisive political symbol.
Back in January, the CDC
was saying healthy people
do not need to wear masks.
The U.S. Surgeon General,
in fact tweeted a message
in which he said, seriously
people, stop buying masks.
But then as we learn more about the virus,
we realize that up to 45%
of patients can be infected
not have any symptoms but
be transmitting that virus
in the respiratory droplets.
And that was the point when
we said, wait a minute,
then mask makes sense, right?
Let everyone wear a mask so
that if they're infected,
then that will contain
those respiratory droplets
and keep them from transmitting
the virus to other people.
We were in an evolving situation.
And when an evolving, unrolling
situation is in effect,
your information will
evolve and you'll be able
to make decisions based on
the most recent information.
The CDC in early April
put out guidance to wear masks.
However, Trump would emphasize
it being a personal choice.
One he often said no to.
I think wearing a face
mask as great presidents,
prime ministers, dictators,
kings, queens, I don't know,
somehow I don't see it for myself.
And while health officials
and even Democratic
rival Joe Biden would
emphatically support masks.
Trump would continue to
avoid being seen in public
wearing one.
If you are on the left
of the political spectrum
you're probably very
concerned about healthcare,
that's probably one of your top issues.
If you're on the right
side of the ideology,
maybe your top concerns
are about foreign policy
or about the economy.
So there was this innate
divide from the beginning
about what exactly should
be the top priority.
And the president just never
really felt that masks were
going to be a panacea and just
never really encouraged them
and people especially his
supporters really adopted that
and that became baked
into the public psyche
that masks were not necessarily
what they should be doing.
Can't you read better without an eye?
No.
I don't wanna fear you.
They don't wanna help me.
By mid April, state and
local state home orders
have fueled a devastating economic impact
for many Americans.
In the harshest downtown for
American workers in history,
employers cut 20.5 million
jobs pushing the jobless rate
to nearly 15%.
And even though Congress
would pass the $2.2 trillion
Cares Act, the largest economic
recovery package in history,
large scale rallies would
erupt all around the country.
We've had enough so, we're practicing.
What you see is our right to
express our heartfelt feelings.
We wanna get back to work.
Trump would show support
for these rallies tweeting,
Liberate Michigan!
Liberate Minnesota and Virginia.
It's an extraordinary
fact that he is siding
with these anti-lockdown activists
and not with his own scientific advisors.
So what do I say to the science?
I say, I don't believe your science
because I believe my God.
The denial of reality
because authority tells you
something, it's stunning,
truly surprised me,
the depth and the extent of it.
We have a historic pandemic,
that's ravaging the world
and in our country and we're not alone,
some of the European
countries are the same,
there's a degree of political divisiveness
that a public health
issue has assumed strong
political overtones
namely, your one ideology,
believe one thing, another
ideology believe another.
Masks work, masks don't work.
It's a hoax, it's real.
It's just extraordinary
going through this right now,
I think is unprecedented.
There was Some feeling in The
White House that this virus
was so contagious that
it was almost inevitable
that people were going to get it.
Then at some point, the
Trump administration decided
that the best message was, let's
just wait for this vaccine.
In late April Bloomberg breaks news
of Operation Warp Speed.
A Manhattan project style,
U.S. government led effort
to drastically cut the time
needed to develop a vaccine.
The project's goal was
to have 300 million doses
of a COVID vaccine by January 2021.
The Trump administration
absolutely deserves
a lot of credit for Operation Warp Speed.
I mean, the amount of
money that was poured in
by the administration was extraordinary.
Billions and billions of dollars
Through Operation Warp Speed, the U.S.
had a war chest of $18 billion to invest
in COVID-19 vaccines and treatments.
The idea back then that a
vaccine would be the way out
of this was a really
difficult thing to comprehend
because if you look at
the timelines it takes
to get vaccines developed
and you know, the majority
of which are not even successful
but it can take around
a decade to get a successful
vaccine to market.
So the idea that you could get a vaccine
in sort of 12 to 18 month
timeframe that would be sufficient
to help the world emerge from
this pandemic was quite crazy
at the beginning.
In late spring, early summer,
you saw a number of countries
like the U.K., the U.S. and the
European Union particularly,
step up and create programs
that would allow them
to accelerate the
development of the vaccines
and also fund the vaccines
on a wide ranging platform
to give multiple shots on
goal for their countries,
those regions, to have
something successful.
We saw similar efforts
in China and in Russia
with their own national
vaccines that they were trialing
and investing in and funding
for their populations.
In the past, worldwide vaccine development
was starved for funding.
Big pharma and biotech firms
usually focus on more lucrative
areas like cancer treatments.
From spring to summer,
a number of vaccines
would begin trials, particularly
promising with vaccines
using a new technology
called messenger RNA.
Being developed by Moderna
and the Pfizer BioNTech partnership.
We get this little piece of messenger RNA
which is relatively unstable,
that's why we have to keep it frozen.
We have this messenger
RNA deliver the message
that the sales need so that
then we can mount a response
to this virus and in
the end it's destroyed.
And even though its timeline was slightly
behind other leading candidates,
a vaccine being developed
by Oxford scientists and
drug maker AstraZeneca
would get a lot of early attention.
The AstraZeneca/Oxford vaccine has really
had an outsize impact on supply agreements
because not only can it be
stored at refrigerator conditions
which makes it much more
conducive to be deployed
to the developing world but it also,
is gonna be sold at cost during
the period of the pandemic
which makes it much more feasible
for countries to purchase
huge doses of the vaccine.
So when you're thinking
about which horse to back,
AstraZeneca/Oxford was a really
good bet at the beginning
of the pandemic for both
success, deployment, cost,
and just the potential
to be really effective
in ending the pandemic.
As scientists rush to develop a vaccine,
a summer surge of cases emerges worldwide.
Any hope that warmer
weather would tame the virus
is dashed.
As it continued its rampage across Europe
and the developing world,
particularly India, Brazil
and South Africa.
However China's strict
lockdowns have allowed for life
to return to normal for many citizens.
Back in the United States,
while cases in the Northeast
stabilized, premature lifting
of lockdowns caused a spike
of cases in the sunbelt.
And by September, Midwest States
experienced a dramatic rise
in COVID-19 cases with South Dakota alone
having a 166% increase and 10 other States
reporting record one day increases.
The annual Sturgis
Motorcycle Rally, school
and university reopenings and
Labor Day weekend celebrations
have all been cited as case links.
Yet nobody was quite
expecting a viral outbreak
in the West wing of The White House.
When I heard that Hope
Hicks, one of the President's
closest advisors had the
virus, we immediately started
thinking it's possible
that the President had it.
Word has come that one
of President Trump's
closest aides, Hope
Hicks has tested positive
for Corona virus and in fact
is apparently quite sick.
The fact that we reported
on Hope's illness,
sent a signal to The White
House that we've got deep
sourcing that they probably
can't hide this from us.
That no matter what happens,
someone is gonna find out.
And I know that people think
that there was a good chance
that if we hadn't reported
on Hope Hicks's diagnosis,
that it's possible we
never would have known
about the President's diagnosis.
The President of the United
States now confirming
to the world that he and the
first lady of the United States
have both tested positive
for the coronavirus
and they will quarantine.
President Trump received Dexamethasone,
Remdesivir and a cocktail
of therapeutic antibodies
from drug maker Regeneron
that was not yet available
to the public.
At the same time, more
officials were testing positive.
Breaking news, it's fair
to say there is an outbreak
within The White House.
Kellyanne Conway has tested
positive for the Corona virus.
Governor Chris Christie now reports
that he has tested positive.
Stephen Miller, a senior aide
to President Trump has become
the 24th person connected
to The White House to test
positive for COVID-19.
There was a very much
worry about it spreading
throughout the entire West wing.
There was worry about his
re-election prospects.
There was worry about how
this was going to affect
their entire plan until
the November 3rd election.
But after several days in Walter Reed,
President Trump would be released
and would return to The White House.
Walking out on his own,
this image over to getting
attention back at The White House
tonight appearing eager to take
off that mask and signaling
tonight he'll be back at
the campaign trail soon.
However, just a little over a month later,
in a record breaking election turnout,
Trump would lose to democratic
challenger, Joe Biden.
Here's your final tally
in the electoral college,
this is for the history books, Wolf.
306 electoral votes for Joe Biden,
232 electoral votes for Donald Trump.
As you noted, that is an exact reversal
of what it was four years ago.
His advisors do know that the
handling of the coronavirus
by The White House and
by the President himself
and his refusal to model some
of the public health measures
that could have at least put
a dent in the coronavirus,
probably killed his re-election.
As Trump's legal team
aggressively challenged
the election's outcome,
there were huge developments
on the vaccine front.
On November 9th, the
Pfizer/BioNTech vaccine
reported to show a more
than 90% efficacy rating.
A week later Moderna's vaccine
would report 94.5% efficacy.
I was saying, boy, I'll take
a 70% effective vaccine,
65% effective vaccine,
it will be very helpful.
It won't crush the outbreak
but it'd be very helpful.
To get 95% effective
vaccines from two candidates
that were the same platform
but different companies,
with essentially identical
results, 94%, 95% efficacy,
I was overwhelmingly pleasantly surprised
that that was the case.
So, that's the one
thing I did not predict.
In the first week of December,
the U.K. was the first
declare the use of a new shot
from Pfizer Inc and BioNTech SE.
The U.S. would do the same a week later.
The approval of Moderna's
vaccine would follow later
in the month.
Not long after, people aged
80 and over in the U.K.
began receiving the vaccine.
The U.K. as the first
doses of the corona vaccine
are being injected into patients.
The country's mass national
vaccination program
has officially began and
to put this into context,
this comes less than a year
after the first case of COVID-19.
Vaccines being shipped
to healthcare workers
came as a welcome relief.
As the U.S. death toll surpasses 325,000.
Global deaths top 1.7 million.
And reports of a new
variant out of the U.K.
show some mutations that
appear to make the virus
even more contagious.
By the end of 2020, millions
of people were expected
to be inoculated.
By the end of 2021 public health
officials in some countries
aim to have 60% to 70% of
that populations immunized,
yet skeptics say that may be a challenge.
I think we're gonna be
far short of the vaccine
we're gonna need in the
first two to three quarters
of next year in the United States.
I think that's still gonna be a challenge.
And there's the logistics
and distribution.
Then there's finding the money,
then there's all the
coordination, it's just a big job.
And having seen the challenges
that world leaders have faced
in actually dealing with the
infection and trying to find
a way to work on the infection,
I'm thinking they will also
face challenges with the immunization.
And even if the rollout of the vaccine
in the U.S. and the world goes swimmingly,
it brings up an entirely new problem.
I think we have kind of a
double-edged sword challenge
of early on we're gonna
have many early adopters
that want the vaccine and we're
not gonna have nearly enough
which is gonna create its own crisis.
Followed by what I'm afraid
will be vaccines sitting there
waiting to find a arm.
About a 1/4 of Americans do
not wanna get vaccinated.
The skepticism represents
a challenge as the country
tries to control exploding infections,
hospitalizations and deaths.
Many are wary of the
vaccine's unprecedented
speed, others are polarized by politics.
The depth of the scientific
hostility to science,
anti-science, which
spills over into anti-vac,
truly surprised me.
There are certain regions of
the country where in the very
towns, counties, cities,
where the hospitals
are being overrun with COVID-19 patients,
there are people in that
area, which are still saying
it's a hoax, it's fake
news, it doesn't exist.
It's mind boggling to see that.
The U.S. and U.K. have
reserved enough vaccines
to inoculate between 150% and nearly 300%
of their population.
But poorer countries like
Vietnam, Ukraine and Uganda,
so far only have enough allocated
to them to cover about 5%
of their populations under
an international vaccine
acquisition group.
I want to ask all world
leaders to ask themselves,
are they viewing this
from a truly international
perspective or are they
viewing it from a parochial
national perspective?
Ultimately, the impact
of COVID will be felt
for years to come and how
leaders around the world
not only learn from this
past year but preparing
future years will determine the
extent of the next outbreak.
It's not if but when the
next pandemic occurs.
We do understand how
important it is to be prepared
and hopefully we will
take the necessary steps
to be prepared.
We need to push the science
and we need to follow scientific advice.
We need to learn to trust
our public health officials
and we need to have that
united voice moving forward.
So that hopefully in future pandemics,
we won't be divided as a country.
While many things went wrong throughout
the year, when it comes to
COVID, there are still victories
that warrant cautious optimism.
I think one of the things
that we did do right
was getting a vaccine into patients.
I am totally impressed by
the way in which scientists
everywhere have cooperated
like never before
on the vaccination.
And also, honestly I wanted
to say that the companies
have done pretty well too.
We will need a lot more of that kind
of radical collaboration
for the vaccination process.
Not only do we have to
continue doing what we've done
but we have to actually
redouble our efforts to stretch
our collaboration potential
for the sake of the future
of humanity quite honestly.